hello you know anyone who's thinking of
proposing so no I'm asking because we
have this opportunity to do this video
with the holiday called Synthesia and
they've been native dubbing which is
sort of like they could make me look
like I speak a language that I'll speak
like it's dubbing but with all the
facial movements much more accurate like
Obama yeah exactly like that so I think
if there was a way to do like a proposal
or something you know that I'm married
right but then I've never been proposed
to and Marga doesn't speak Mandarin
either so maybe we haven't proposed to
me Edie hi I'm Marty and we've been
married for three years
Oh more than two years we met at a place
I was working at I was working on an
oyster bar and Edie came in to eat there
a few times and one time I was like
never for my friend no that's not the
story of my effort oh we have different
versions my version of the story is -
the third time I went there I was like
hey can I have a number and he wrote
down his number on the oyster menu and
gave it to me that's how it started when
we first met Edie was still on my f1
lines as a student it came to the point
where I neither need to get a work visa
or I might need to leave the country and
then he just goes I don't want to leave
let's just get married everything was
going so fast and unfortunately we
didn't have the typical proposal and it
got rushed insofar as that aspect this
year we finally had the chance to go
back to China and celebrate with my
family at the banquet I had to write a
speech for everybody to know kind of
where I was coming from and what we had
been through it was hard for Edie to
play translator the whole time
oh yeah I was exhausted it was like a
double speech which would have been a
lot easier if I was able to speak
Mandarin so today I'm going to be
proposing for the first time by using
this technique
I will be able to see Marty proposing to
me in Mandarin there will be three
different reveals you know first me
seeing myself and hearing myself speak
Mandarin secondly edy getting a proposal
that she deserves which is kind of the
way that marriage is typically work and
then thirdly for her parents to hear me
speak Mandarin as well as see me propose
and like some former fashion that they
would be able to understand this is
Marty can speak Mandarin we found our
family friend who's gonna say the
translated speech marty is very talented
in his words in expressing his feelings
so I look forward to it also I secretly
hope that he will also get inspired to
finally decide to learn Mandarin I
honestly don't know how most proposals
happen I like to do like off-the-cuff
things to most guys write proposals down
to like repeat to who they're proposing
to do I don't know I'm honestly really
excited but also nervous because I have
really high standard I'm pretty used to
her being picky but I think that she's
only a picky about certain things when
somebody's trying to express how they
feel for somebody I don't think that
she's like oh well you better say this
so I don't think that you know anything
like that is gonna happen but I could be
wrong so busy has a company where we're
developing video reanimation technology
which basically allows us to fix the
traditional kung fu style dubbing
utilizing new branch of AI called
generative AI this is all about
translating content from one language to
another so the way that this technology
works is that first forget my to do a
quick calibration sequence I'm gonna go
over some of the stuff that I've written
for the proposal I'm gonna get my face
mapped for the software to work and pray
that everything goes well we just run
through this group of the prompt which
is the normal
that quick beige fox one that quick
beige fox that quick beige fox that
quick beige fox how long I think I put
that up then we move on to training our
AI software who learn his facial
dynamics the way we do this is with some
interview style speaking to camera what
do you most enjoy about living in Los
Angeles oh yeah that's gonna be a short
answer
alright so now we're gonna be going into
the actual proposal reading eating we
have been really busy working with
trying to make money to facilitate our
goals it's like it's moving slow there's
not swelling at that point I wish we
could go back in time I wish we could go
back in time I wish we could go back in
time that's sort of hard to control that
but try to keep your eyes in the same
spot on the telephone okay still rolling
everyone settle just take your time with
it I wish we could go back in time I'm
still going damn then be ready to bring
interest weigh our topping actor and he
has translate the script from English
into Mandarin et you directly translate
to another language the words means
exactly same word I worked but the
sentence actually changes a little bit
so I changed original script a little
bit made it more sounds like a proposal
and the Chinese would Marty's always
good at expressing his emotions he will
always tell me how he feels about me
however since it's gonna be someone
else's voice that could be a little
weird then we bring back the footage our
algorithms to work with essentially
transfer the dubbing actors facial
movements onto Maddie's face along with
the audio track this is what makes it
look like Maddie's actually speaking in
Mandarin I think the worst-case scenario
would be the video would work too well
and the translation would be off and I
would just be saying something that's
totally crazy I do suspect we get a
quick handshake for you guys
I'm placing you so it's been a couple
weeks we just got the video back and I'm
excited to watch it
how about you I think the reaction will
be somewhat surprised but mostly
pleasant so let's see how if I'm right
or not
so comb it you just don't seem to be
quite as calm of course I won't be
because I've never been proposed to and
this is my official proposal so I hope I
hear what I want
[Music]
well may you joking mom mother tongues
hand well just to say move down what she
won't work here without God she so easy
want me lunch on the city sandy children
since I was something evil what song
sound
what kind of you paid the job without
you go ungentle mother than you can say
well yeah
Sharon we can honking sound out again
tomorrow holy Jamie and showdown
Cucaracha Donegan yourself which would
be hard to see the negative you talent
nijo he had a number one me obviously
had a point to some horrible with you
you two might see that Sunil Yamato to
lower the suit suits you know when to
down the 11:30 critical no matter the
charger was inside out of the way for me
and I'm hopeful but you don't need
yosakoi who will come to you some the
Netherland colony organs at Honda Sicily
deny people who sell finito such so we
are destined to you - happy / one may
know who you are abilities in woman the
bids number you're sensing each other Oh
Colonel
Sunita what a liar hollow her hanging
we're gonna need aha no mention my pits
that we were in what do you are again it
was negative a harder yet he needs a gay
one
Wow perfect like I'm Aaron I've been
really busy and sometimes I forget about
being patient it's different for me
because I remember what I said and what
he said and how it the both came
together it's I mean it's pretty
flawless but it was hard for me to get
over seeing it because it was such a
mind I don't know if there's a better
word for that when the video first
started playing I didn't notice oh it is
Marty's face Marty's facial movement but
it is someone else's voice however as it
goes on
I was just paying attention to what he's
trying to say to me it was beautiful I'm
really happy how do you think your
parents are gonna react
they take surprise pretty well so far
because our decision of getting married
is the biggest surprise I never told
them until a month before we decided
okay we're gonna get married
[Music]
honest to 200 melchio hundreds and
Wasilla gostrey Adeline genée gentlemen
journey out to your holiday show that
you know Marley tornado Marengo don't
make John sure that show off under the
eye so you know anyone kind of she looks
great
my appearance speaks a little bit
English but not enough to say like
everything so I think my parents has
always hope Marty will learn Mandarin I
really hope that the video can help
bridge a language barrier and they can
see him the way I see him soon you know
what social over the Shu said she you
know what pseudo-element AET Creek offal
no matter the charger when Edie's mother
came out here we used a lot of
translation apps so I think that being
able to speak Mandarin through
any means even if it's somebody else
speaking will be a big thing for them
because it's a big milestone you are
again nutrition negative a heart again
Edie you ain't IA woman sound mother
Marley shoulders of a hardcover gentle
Yojimbo [ __ ] fascinating
AOS you can tone down even one William a
tiny mention me I will put it on Market
Street to pester me or you pull a
two-month-old of one your mount without
do description thank wanna do which kind
of juicy wasting potato salad or so
dollar [ __ ] finally tell me Marlene I
know right at how do I don't think Emile
stand on you and she got caisson that
was good I'm happy we did this
it was a little afraid don't doing this
I'm not sure why but I'm gonna often
yeah I'm glad we did this too I think it
was pretty cool we've been really busy
and then sometimes we don't have time
you know to take a moment and think back
and think deeper about I don't know I'm
taking this too far cause everything
started and sometimes you're just like
you're comfortable yeah you get
comfortable and you're like okay it's
it's taken for granted
yeah you take it see you know I really I
want to say it's very special for my
appearance to I don't think people get
opportunities like this but I'm so happy
we did it I think as with any technology
it's a tool that you can use for good
and for bad and I think technology
sector as a whole and us as a company
has responsibility in making sure that
we roll this out in a safe way on the
positive side of a cultural exchange and
greatly accelerated and I think the
concept of recording today is a great
example of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]